[Applause]
[Music]
Afghanistan is a difficult country in
many aspects and difficult honestly
doesn't really cover it
Afghanistan is a very mountainous
country almost three-quarters of its
surface is covered by mountains and
peaks that in many cases exceed 20,000
feet so you can probably imagine just
how difficult communications are among
the different regions of this country
and as if this was not enough it's also
a landlocked and mostly arid place in
fact deserts are not unusual at all in
Afghanistan so despite a few valleys its
national landscape is mainly composed of
red and yellow tones but geography is
not the worst part of this country and
neither is its harsh climate conditions
not at all in fact poverty corruption
and especially fundamentalism and
violence are the worst parts of this
place Afghanistan's a viewer above all
is a country of war in 1878 the Sauer
Revolution a communist based revolution
took place one year later in 1979 the
Soviet army invaded the country to
consolidate the communist government
since then the people have not known
what peace means but before to be honest
the situation it wasn't really good
either Afghanistan was theirs and
probably will be for a long time one of
the poorest countries on earth it's also
got one of the hardest and most hostile
living conditions especially for women
in this country six out of every ten
people don't how to read or write almost
half of its population doesn't have
access to drinking water and it's
difficult to find a single family which
hasn't been devastated by war and
violence we can safely say that if
someone was able to choose where they
were to be born no one would ever choose
Afghanistan the last great conflict
which still persists to this day burst
onto the global stage in October of 2001
when the President of the United States
at the time George W Bush decided to
invade Afghanistan as a response to 9/11
at that time Afghanistan was led by the
Taliban a radical religious political
group which protected members of al
Qaeda including Osama bin Laden on my
orders the United States military has
begun strikes against al Qaeda terrorist
training camps and military
installations of the Taliban regime in
Afghanistan the invasion it was fast
the Taliban simply weren't an obstacle
for the massive American war machine 16
years and three presidents later though
and it has been named by many as the
longest war in US history it's already
longer than the war in Vietnam and
believe it or not the u.s. they're not
winning that war
[Music]
what's happening
16 long years of conflicts occupation
and hundreds of billions of dollars
later and it would seem logical to think
that the US and NATO could have managed
to have the situation under control and
Afghanistan would be close to reaching
peace right well nothing is further from
reality the truth is that with each day
that goes by the Taliban regain grounds
just take a look at this map from The
Washington Post the colored areas are
the ones controlled by the Taliban and
well this map shows the situation at the
beginning of 2017 but today things are
even worse because as we've just said
the Taliban are regaining ground almost
every day the most recent estimates show
that the governments of Kabul US and
NATO control less than 60% of the
territory and the next map is going to
show even more Taliban controlled
regions the Afghan government controls
just 57% of its territory us watchdog
says but the loss of control by the
Afghan governments and thus the u.s.
shouldn't be just seen as a territorial
loss but also an economic loss for
example it's really important that we
ask ourselves how can the Taliban
finance their activity where do all of
their resources come from well basically
that would be from heroin production as
you might know Afghanistan is the
biggest opium producer in the world
and this opium well that's the raw
ingredient that is used in heroin and
listen Afghanistan is not just the
world's biggest producer
it controls between 80 and 90% of opium
production globally
the opium comes from Papa sauver samne
from the most popular plant among the
Afghan opium farmers in this country
most of the population lives off farming
we can say that most of the Afghan
economy relies on two fields that's
international soldiers and opium in fact
there's little more to their economy
than that so for quite a while the
Taliban have controlled the opium
production in this country but now they
also have realized that they can produce
the heroin themselves which is a much
more profitable activity and well that's
exactly what they're doing everything
they harvest is duly processed inside
the country they receive more revenue if
they process the opium before it has
left the country William Brown field
u.s. assistant secretary for drugs and
law enforcement estimates show that the
Taliban could be raising about three
billion dollars every year from this and
that's despite all the money that the US
has wasted trying to stop these
activities and effort this as you can
see from this chart hasn't been at all
helpful
[Music]
so despite all the effort made by the
u.s. opium production remains at very
high levels as a consequence of having
all of these resources the Taliban
they're managing to sustain a war that
is not just allowing them to regain
ground but has also plunged the country
into violence and worst of all is that
future predictions they're not very good
the Taliban are getting stronger the
government is on the retreat they're
losing ground the Taliban day by day
abdul-jabbar Caramon a retired general
listen to this the Taliban army has
increased from between two thousand to
ten thousand soldiers in 2005 to more
than 60,000 today but at this point the
question has become why is the u.s.
losing this war or at least why aren't
they winning
[Music]
the Afghan trap the United States has
tried many different strategies in
Afghanistan but it seems that nothing is
working in fact generally speaking
there's quite a lot of pessimism over
this conflict and this is not just a
matter of more or less soldiers when
Barack Obama was a candidate for
president he repeated all the time that
Afghanistan was a war they need to win
did not finish the job against al Qaeda
in Afghanistan we did not develop new
capabilities to defeat a new enemy or
launch a comprehensive strategy to dry
up the terrorist base of support
we did not reaffirm our basic values or
secure our homeland it's time to turn
the page when I am president we will
wage a war that has to be won Barack
Obama when he arrived to the White House
he deployed 100,000 soldiers and another
40,000 from NATO even so nothing changed
many experts say that the problem is
that President Obama insisted all the
time on an exit plan with a troop
withdrawal calendar which is sort of
like saying to the Taliban hey look you
know don't worry about any of this it's
all temporary but beyond that although
the soldiers from the International
Coalition gained ground they couldn't
gain influence and now the question is
why is that well first of all we're
talking about a tribal country with a
culture of consolidated violence it's
not easy for international troops to
gain people's trust and be able to
distinguish civilians from enemies or
even just know what's happening on the
ground the cultural leave is absolutely
huge and having suffered so many years
of violence means that the Taliban
plenty of experience on the other hand
there's the corruption and the lack of
credibility in the local government we
can safely say that the Afghan
government has a total lack of
institutions which can provide anything
to the Afghan people and while there are
a very few that do exist they are
extremely corrupt in fact this is one of
the most corrupt countries on earth
ordinary Afghans don't like the Taliban
but they dislike the Afghan government
even more people don't die for an army
they die for a country and who wants to
die for the current Afghan government
Dexter Filkins New Yorker reporter with
all of this considered and also adding
in the fear of the Taliban it's easy to
understand why every month almost 4,000
soldiers and policemen deserted the
government of Kabul further we have to
say that the strategy the u.s. has taken
with the Afghan government
the politics and the institutions it
hasn't worked Washington hasn't even
made the Afghan military able to
function with the exception of the
Special Forces which is formed of 17,000
elite soldiers they are the only ones
who are really fighting the Taliban
Barack Obama understood that the war in
Afghanistan was something that the
Afghan people should carry out though
the US would be the one paying the bills
today I signed a historic agreement
between the United States and
Afghanistan that defines a new kind of
relationship between our countries a
future in which Afghans are responsible
for the security of their nations among
all the problems we also have to add in
one Pakistan who is being accused of
providing support to the Taliban and to
an economy which doesn't work at all and
then there's three a lot of concealed
interests for example have you thought
about what interests Beijing Tehran or
Moscow having this war one thing is
clear these countries don't want
Afghanistan to be an American colony
because of all of this after 16 years of
war the battle it continues but now that
the Oval Office is a new President
Donald Trump
a huge mistake Trump has been saying for
years that the war in Afghanistan is a
huge mistake and that the US has to get
out of that he said it of course through
his favorite communication medium and
that would be Twitter he repeated it
again and again in 2011 2012 2013 all
the way until his 2016 campaign when
will we stop wasting our money on
rebuilding Afghanistan we must rebuild
our country first it's time to get out
of Afghanistan we're building roads and
schools for people that hate us it's not
in our national interest do not allow
our very stupid leaders to sign a deal
that keeps us in Afghanistan through
2024 with all costs by USA make America
great now Obama is keeping our soldiers
in Afghanistan for at least another year
he is losing two wars simultaneously and
his noticed Twitter Trump insisted again
and again and again that Afghanistan was
a mistake have a look at this
Afghanistan is a total and complete
disaster what are we doing get out of
Afghanistan we've wasted billions and
billions of dollars and more importantly
thousands and thousands of lives and of
course in the presidential campaign he
promised he will get the u.s. out of
Afghanistan if elected but well now that
he's president well things they seem to
be rather different
[Music]
Trump's new position on the 21st of
August in the military base of Fort Myer
in Virginia Trump explained his brand
new strategy bangs well let's just say
that everything has been saying for
years well it came to nothing Trump's
new strategy is so similar to Obama's
that it's really quite difficult to
differentiate them Trump announced more
troops but not that many more basically
the contingent will increase from 12,000
to about 16,000 the training of the
Afghan military in the fight against
terrorism will become a priority more
money will be spent corruption will be
battles and there will be more pressure
on Pakistan so in other words more of
the same and nothing that the US hasn't
done before the main differences from
Obama's strategy though are twofold
first there won't be a withdraw or
calendar and second Trump seems not to
be interested in building Afghan
institutions in fact with the budget
cuts on the State Department Trump seems
to rely more on arms than on politics
and it's not clear what Trump tends to
do with 16,000 soldiers that Obama
couldn't do with a hundred and forty
thousand or how he thinks he can
stabilize a country without solid and
reliable institutions which could gain
local people's trust and allow for some
economic developments I mean the average
age in Afghanistan is around 18 years
old which is an incredibly young
population and this youth nowadays can't
work and doesn't have any future apart
from what the Taliban can offer them if
Kabul or Washington are not able to
build a framework of opportunities for
these people the end of violence will be
very far away so the question must be is
Donald Trump aware of this it's going to
be only America first America first so
16 years more than 800 billion dollars
and thousands and thousands of military
and civilian losses later and the United
States is still bogged down in what many
call the Afghan trap and the truth is
that Trump doesn't seem to propose
anything different without institutions
and without a multilateral willingness
which must include Afghanistan's
neighbors like China it seems very hard
to believe that weapons are going to be
enough and now it's your turn
what do you think the US should do in
Afghanistan it's a pretty big question
you can leave us your opinion in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for brand new
videos every
day and Thursday also please do check
out our friends at the reconsider media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine and as always
thank you for watching my original
instant was to pull out and historically
I like following my instincts but all my
life I've heard that decisions are much
different when you sit behind the desk
in the Oval Office in other words when
you're President of the United States